- We'll get five suggestions
and then do a little freestyle.
I'll come to this kind of area first.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Male Audience Member] Game of Thrones!
- Game of Thrones? Blast from the past!
What specifically would you like me
to rap about in Game of Thrones,
bearing mind not everyone
here may have seen it,
and I think it's still within the kind of,
you know, period where
we should let people
maybe watch on their own and
without spoiling too much, so.
- [Male Audience Member] Incest!
- Incest? Okay, cool. (audience laughter)
As he says, first episode, really.
It's quite good when a show is just like,
"look, you've gotta be
on board with this."
Cool. Incest in Game of Thrones.
People in this kind of triangular
shape that I'm drawing up,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Male Crowd Member] Wales!
- Okay, so--
- [Female Audience Member] Fortnite.
- One second, you said
Fortnite, you said Wales.
But when you say Wales, do you mean whales
or the kind of Principality
of Wales in the--
- [Male Crowd Member] Principality!
- Yeah, I know it's not
really a principality, is it?
But it sounds fun if I say
that. Are you Welsh, boyo?
- [Male Crowd Member]
No, but I have no idea
what principality even means.
- You have no idea what
principality means. That's fine.
It's not, I'm just being silly.
Well, I guess, I guess, I guess-
because Charles is Prince of
Wales in a way it must be,
but I, I mean, it's a country term, right?
Wales. Cool. And you said Fortnite.
Again, why are all our touchstones tonight
four years out of date?
Well I-- Game of Thrones.
Fortnite. Do you play Fortnite?
- [Female Audience Member] A little bit.
- A little bit. A little bit.
Oh, I mean, if you still play it now
that means you must be reasonably into it.
Yeah? What's your favorite-
What, what do you enjoy about
Fortnite? I've never played.
- [Female Audience Member]
All right, so you're building,
constructing buildings while--
- Constructing the buildings? I like this.
This is real--
- [Female Audience Member]
That's mostly what I do.
- Mostly what you like.
Everyone else is running
around trying to kill people,
and you're like, I'm
trying to make a tower.
Why are you shooting
at me? Okay, cool, so-
building in Fortnite, Game of
Thrones and incest, and Wales.
People, I guess, in this shape.
I'm gonna say it's a trapezoid?
What would you like a rap about?
- [Male Audience Fan] Princess Di.
- Princess Di? Yeah. You've
be watching The Crown? Yeah.
Do you- you look- I mean,
you're a pretty blonde lady.
Are you- is he gonna
take you in a car later?
(audience laughter)
- Princess Di.
Princess Diana, for those
of you who don't know.
Lady Diana Spencer. Cool.
It's being very royal.
Very royal. We've got Wales and Lady Di.
And then- and people over here,
you have the final suggestion
and I would like it
to be better than all
of these suggestions.
(audience laughter)
- That's not a criticism of your quality!
Just that, you know- they're all good,
but I'm sure you guys can come
up with an absolute banger.
- [Female Crowd Member] Dental hygiene.
- Dental Hygiene? Thank you.
And again, feels pretty
pointed given my nationality.
(audience laughter)
- So, building in Fortnite,
Lady Di, Wales, dental hygiene,
and you have to remind me of your one.
- [Male Audience Member] Incest!
- Incest in Game of Thrones.
I feel like it's really moved away
from the fantasy HBO series and
it's just purely incest now.
Okay, well, this then, lovely people.
It's a freestyle. That's
a rap made upon the spot,
based entirely on suggestions.
You're shaking your head as if you dread
the fact this is even going to happen.
You cannot leave. I'm
gonna put this down here
because I loathe to put
my phone on the floor.
And is that- look at these rings!
These are very nice and sparkly.
Your nails are well
done, as well. Well done!
Please don't kill her in a
car accident. She's very nice.
Cool. This is a freestyle
about all that shit.
Let's have some fun.
(beat music)
♪ We hope you have a
safe end to your night ♪
♪ Don't crash in the tunnel that we had ♪
♪ with Lady Diana Spencer, yet alive. ♪
♪ Now she dead, right on her
side that was fired, yeah ♪
♪ The son of the man running,
heart in the London ♪
♪ If you are in the '90s,
yeah, not a fun one ♪
♪ I remember, woke up late, 8:00 a.m. ♪
♪ I went down, wanted cartoons,
I ate them up on the TV ♪
♪ Then I turned it on,
I'm like, what's this? ♪
♪ Why's the head gone wrong? ♪
♪ Why she put a head through
the steering wheel? ♪
♪ I went upstairs to my mum and dad, ♪
♪ Then I peeled off the
tears of laughter, ♪
♪ The tears of sadness,
I said, "yo, mum!" ♪
♪ I think something batshit
is happening downstairs ♪
♪ She said, "don't swear" ♪
♪ I said, "but Lady Diana Spencer!" ♪
♪ I probably didn't know
the technical surname ♪
♪ I probably said Princess
Di and felt pain ♪
♪ She died like we had
an "E" to her name ♪
♪ In the little fireball,
in all of the flame ♪
♪ Caused by the paparazzis ♪
♪ But do you mind? You
talk about her death ♪
♪ You should talk about
the landmines charity ♪
♪ That she claimed going down ♪
♪ I've actually never watched
a season of The Crown ♪
♪ I prefer all the fantasy from long ago ♪
♪ Dragon's coming down, halflings, HBO ♪
♪ And on the first episode of that show ♪
♪ They push a little boy
out the top of a window ♪
♪ Why, because he spied the two
little people getting naked? ♪
♪ He's like, this doesn't
make sense, can't take it ♪
♪ You're having sex, rubbing
close, but I disagree ♪
♪ Why? Because you're related,
upon all the family tree ♪
♪ You've got the queen
and Jaime Lannister ♪
♪ She'd be naked with the boob out ♪
♪ He be got his hand on her, ♪
♪ This is before his hand turns to gold ♪
♪ That's the spoiler, anyway, ♪
♪ The incest, it annoys many people ♪
♪ They'd be like, this isn't real. ♪
♪ Now, if you've got a fit
sister, that's how you'd feel ♪
♪ You'd like go (audience
laughter) give the go ♪
♪ So they put that urge
there in the show ♪
♪ And that's totally
fine, having such fun ♪
♪ I never failed to enjoy my food ♪
♪ When I'm over there in Wales, ♪
♪ I get some Welsh
cheese, it's sent to me ♪
♪ How do I eat it? Carefully!
That's a fun cheese ♪
♪ If you've ever been there, ♪
♪ Different kind of cheese, I'm aware ♪
♪ They've got the little
daffodils, got a lot of leeks ♪
♪ They sound kind of weird
every time that they speak ♪
♪ They eat a lot of "L"s, it
sounds like they're choking ♪
♪ Can't do the acting
properly because it's broken ♪
♪ It's kinda weird, a fact
that I'll share to you ♪
♪ If you try and sound
Welsh, it's similar ♪
♪ To sounding like you are from India. ♪
♪ Therefore, I don't go to
the accent, moving over here ♪
♪ Yeah, I know you're attacking it ♪
♪ The plaque that, I mean,
the back of your molars ♪
♪ A dental hygienist just
strolls over and says, ♪
♪ Ah, I understand you've
lost all of your teeth ♪
♪ Because you're from England. ♪
♪ Let me clean out all of the food ♪
♪ Take it out here, I'm like,
"sorry, this is rude!" ♪
♪ I'm paying you for a service ♪
♪ All the horrible dismissive
attitude, I not deserve this ♪
♪ I need to get a better
hygienist, there's an offer ♪
♪ She says hygienist, I
say, I'll call a doctor ♪
♪ She's like, they won't even help ♪
♪ They need to fix all your gums ♪
♪ I'm like (tongue out sound)
I just stick at my tongue ♪
♪ She's like, well Chris, yeah,
you think you're the boss ♪
♪ It's fine though. Why? Because
then she starts to floss ♪
♪ And I don't mean with the
tiny little bit of string ♪
♪ I mean she does that
weird online dance move ♪
♪ When you see her do it, I'm
like, "I'll set you straight." ♪
♪ That's how, when you play
Fortnite and celebrate ♪
♪ Like solos (audience cheering) ♪
♪ Shooting people and head
shots, but you're building ♪
♪ Saying, now, this is
not what I thought ♪
♪ The game would be about ♪
♪ I've got all my bricks and mortar, ♪
♪ I'm trying to build a tower.
Oh, it's a thankless task. ♪
♪ I need some little plans. Yes. ♪
♪ And I will ask you: stop shooting me ♪
♪ With guns and missiles ♪
♪ It's a fun way to spend
the time for a while. ♪